we have been honoring veterans all day
and this next story is one that will
truly
inspire you as it did me please take a
look
hi i'm jonathan michael turnbull major
in the united states army i'm 35 years
old living in gaylord michigan with my
wife samantha and our two children ian
and scotty john i always knew i wanted
to serve in the united states army i was
commissioned the second lieutenant
deploying over five times in the last 11
years of service
our focus was not precisely on killing
just bad guys
but ensuring that when we stepped away
from the war zone that the government
was able to step up and take control and
provide security freedoms and rights of
the people we worked to create a safe
place and safe systems in place for over
four thousand girls to return to school
on january 16th in 2019 we had a routine
combat mission that was by one of the
schools where we opened the doors for
the girls to return
just going out and talking with them and
seeing how they were enjoying school i
gave the order of march kind of telling
everybody what the plan was but in
the brief
moment that we were all together an isis
fighter walked up to my group
unbeknownst to us
and detonated a suicide vest
instantly killing three of my teammates
and my linguists
having samantha by my side was an
incredible boost to my recovery
something as simple as playing music in
my hospital room to make me more
cheerful and having her there to hold my
hand and help me through it
today i've had 22 surgeries
i lost my right eye being 100 visually
impaired has been the biggest adjustment
we moved into our new house in june of
this year we're trying to learn where
everything is something simple is trying
to figure out my way around the house
there is a lot of getting used to it but
the one injury that is lost over i guess
for the most part all emotional trauma
on the spiritual trauma from the
explosion
today i work with other veterans telling
them what happened to me so we can
relate to each other and not just
veterans but anybody's gone through
something has a story and i encourage
everybody to talk about it
please welcome here major john turnbull
and his amazing wife samantha
thank you thank you so much you guys
thank you
[Applause]
thank you
samantha
you
found out
about this bombing
on the news yes
i
woke up to my phone just buzzing like
crazy and it was a news app that i had
on my phone and it just had said
multiple troops killed in manbij and i
thought
oh no this is that's where john john's
at and as i'm reading this i got another
notification that said
four troops were killed and i thought
four that's half the team
so how did you find out that john was
alive
later that afternoon his boss and chain
of command they all came to our house at
that point they had said
right now john is alive okay but he's in
really really bad shape
at the time he was only given 12 hours
to live
but he ended up he pulled through oh my
gosh okay and how do you stay in a
mindset of positivity and can do
the power of positivity is incredible i
remember a
gentleman by the name of chaplain
braswell at walter reed told me he's
like what i recommend is uh the power of
positivity is like every time you think
of something and it's negative replace
it with instantly with two positive
thoughts and so that that's one way that
got me through
uh the last two and a half years
i just want to hang on your every word
and keep learning about the power of
positivity from the two of you and i
thank you so much for giving it to us
here
welcome
and
we have a surprise for you um we have
secretly teamed up with the home depot
foundation and tunnel to towers
foundation and they've worked together
over the years building smart homes
for wounded veterans and they build them
so they are custom fit
to their needs and i am so happy to
share that they're going to work with
you to completely renovate your home
and make it accessible specifically to
your needs and that's not all
they're also
going to pay off the remainder of your
mortgage so you can take that off your
plate um and
there's also one last thing um john your
friend and colleague army chief warrant
officer too
jonathan r farmer
who was killed in the 2019 attack
his wife tabitha
is who nominated you for this program
and she has a message for you that i
wanted both of you
to hear
oh my goodness
congratulations turnbulls i am so
excited and grateful that you're
receiving a tunnel to tower smart home i
know that my john is up in heaven just
absolutely beaming that you have
received this amazing well deserving and
generous gift and turnbulls
the farmers love you
wow
[Applause]
she is the strongest person i know
yeah she's by far the family is
incredible but she is just the most
incredible person
that i've ever met um
we love them so
much major jonathan turnbull and
samantha turnbull thank you to the home
depot foundation and the tunnel to
towers foundation
um and thank you for being here truly
[Music]
you